how's it going rest - we're back
welcome to miss out it's made by the
same guy who made mad father and you
bros really dick did I dog MIT we both
diggety diggety let's go enter this
girl's name with the key boy this girl's
name with the key bahahahahahaha
saravana and her name shall be there
Delia that's right
yeah Delia all right Khalil help find me
Bedelia a missile is a missile me sow
love that I could do my own oh I look
beautiful girl Alec party was I was I
dreaming I thought I heard me sow I
guess it was just a dream
it's been three months since what oh no
it's so late I'm gonna be late for
school
so yeah you wait miss our never stood up
out what stood out too much we shall
never stood out too much in our flesh
she was just a simple girl really I
listen too close to her but I was always
worrying about missile being alone I
hope that could be her friend but did it
happen well hey girl you forgot your
teddy three months ago miss our one
missing she wasn't coming to school and
she hadn't come home I either she's not
the type oh she's not the type to flee
home our parents were saying that she
might have gotten involved in something
while I'm off when my titties girl mmm
it says God I require spread the rumor
that miss I was a long dead by now I
really hope they're wrong I want it to
be our friend find me I guess miss I was
calling out for us
um so it kinda uses the same universe as
a mad father as far as I know I'm not
sure sorry I don't know what the details
geez look at that Pokemon graphics so
here and then you are the attractive
teacher of always but he's attractive
alright this is attractive am i
attractive
hahaha attractive student for that I
said popular with students generosity
eighth-note and mr. so hot as cool as
ever triple dot that voice I had my
dream was that Miss au Bedelia shut the
[ __ ] up you've got guts to ignore my
lecture yech this information will be a
sessional for the test you'd better
listen that's when you actually note
[ __ ]
yes sir I'm sorry Kegel so I giggle
[ __ ] hair I can't I can't do this ok
whatever
I dig this music mr. Sun has a near suit
like whoa
super suede who the hell says that -
Delia's best friend a fad following girl
who looks up to mr. Salter Ayaka you've
been talking to him taking him what
you've been talking him up all morning
don't you ever get tired of blabbing but
he's such a ladies man
so nod and smile and best shut the [ __ ]
up [ __ ] oh yeah I gotta use some hand
cream well someone's got a fab in school
that's weird dude dude dude it's at some
code word for fapping did you hear I did
it yeah there's a rumor mrs. soda had a
hand this disc is dirtier and dirtier so
maybe if I clean my hands constantly
every day all the time he liked me more
yes I'm sure that will work out for you
I don't really go oh yeah I don't really
care what she says ha
you got no eye for men Padilla Leah I
got great what seriously what do you see
in the seducer like Hama I never said I
liked anybody I just think it's kind of
cool that's all really hey who the [ __ ]
laughs like that what's up with a dialog
yeah yeah
yes really [ __ ] love this games on
fire oh who the [ __ ] is this guy or girl
there's been some spooky Patenaude about
business going on in the school I'm
getting a little freaked
paranormal my ass fidelia's classmate a
boy carefree and appearance personality
everything oh that's so swellest I'm for
real it's real the other day are killing
all the class got dragged away in the
bathroom I want to make a footprint
bridge like Padilla's class fate leader
of the bully how the [ __ ] is someone
leader of the bullies looking like that
there was also the class in the third
floor hallway being broken from inside
Patel's classmate a calm early maturing
you gotta beg Alice hey I'm scared today
us classmates just otome a for short
Thomas girlfriend ghost huh the best
those ain't exist wait what if this is
mrs. K look this is no time for jokes
but I mean it's like totally possible ah
it's bad luck three monster vanish it's
the stuff the funny stuff if those
events are missiles carrots than your
shin oil beakers you shall be carried
sooner or later what what have I did I
door Yoshino you did pull him is our
line bullying what I never outs it
making a little fun
and promise always close witness ha
you're the one who could you will get
cost me ha I'm fine
masala doctor me I wonder Tama look
scared honey have you gone friend show
me your garage dust wanna Tama
Oh Tala I'll protect ya ah me ha what do
what you like
'la bad without pleasant cars us the
rest our fair game though oops did I say
that loud yeah whoa girl what in
heaven's what the fudge an archaic what
luck it got dark right quick what the
heck is going on may there just maybe as
early as miss our cars miss how do you
mad at us shut out what the hell I was
just thinking about the crap Fidelio Oh
miss Oh miss ow I can hear her speaking
to me what girl you be trippin you be
trippin on my blip oh now it's got to be
happy sure ah boys Fidelia you're
talking crazy talk I'm not uh bye
me interesting stories out hi nice my
tongue
oh wait that's really weird [ __ ]
creepy man I got goosebumps from this I
don't know I thought it was pretty quick
yeah so EE
whoa where am I
I was just in the classroom and who are
you what what
it's that Slenderman guy I'm own ego IRA
the student council president and this
is the student council room luckily for
you you end up somewhere safe ended up
after the earthquake the skull is sucked
into another world okay
I love how you says that old casually
[ __ ] this said those inside flying all
across the school another one what's
that supposed to mean and why wouldn't
bad hat why would that happen well it's
a can't it's a result of a girl's curse
that this school was sealed into another
world
a curse it couldn't be tripled up mr.
president Oni Guevara well what the [ __ ]
is that guy huh
touch pad I finally made it
I thought I was alone so you finally
returned this library they call her miss
library I think they mean listen miss
librarian she is the school vice
president always in the library so
that's what we call her okay so then
miss library how does it look it's
messed up and gone cop and [ __ ] up
into compression and everything is
wrecked I hadn't be able to find any
exists plus Ava spares I go in attacking
people I saw a student killed before my
okay
that's nice I'll never be able to eat
hamburgers again what oh it was
frightening it's totally appropriate
sentence so I see thank you for your
report you may retire for now yes well
I'm going back to the library call
anytime you ninny she can't looks like
Carly Jepsen reps and read/write evil
spirits the curse must have summoned
them what's cool is now Dennis pairs and
no one is really tan um there's only one
solution
I'm doing this guy's cars they're subtly
no Hardaway surely no other way
how am I supposed to undo a curse [ __ ]
by saving the girl's soul Mizpah Delia
you must know what it is you had to do I
do find me trip a lot miss I was calling
me so she wants to be found
mr. Oni gawa I'll go back I look for
miss out so you will as librarian for me
it's called a full of inner space and
yet you wish to go I will because it
sounds my friend gay sorry understood
you are entrusted with the fate of the
school I believe you can do it
blah but if [ __ ] blah blabbetty
[ __ ] e blah see all right we're
getting to play you can press C or shift
to make a quick say so I can say
whenever I want I pray for your safety
okay that's that's convenient hydro
check as we go are you scared I'm a
little freaked out by this because I
don't really know what's going on I'm
just cute little girl like I'm a as a
book here let's read it
principal's diary swatted and cloudy the
murder X fell out of the vase somebody
pick it up [ __ ] it fell out of the vase
spit ow
you pick oh okay
there was this poison it courses through
pitiless body and I die not gonna die
her whoa holy [ __ ] I did not
keep going as a zombie I'm exactly well
down we shall go a vending machine buy
some juice
[ __ ] yeah I gotta buy juice ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah what if I got here but that's
wonderful
Oh job La Follette
that's a good scare right there I'll be
enjoyed yourself a challenge like that
that's glad things with Honda breath
today it really helps me out a lot and
I'll see you and your pure face later